also man kennt seine gäste alle
hildegard schweinsberg kennt alle und
jeden denn sie ist seit mehr als 70
jahren hinter diesen krisen zu gange
jeden tag mindestens 50 bier gezapft
macht 15.000 pro jahr im 70 jahren
locker eine million bier am zapfhahn
macht ihr keiner was vor
das kann man nicht erklären das kann man
das kann man lernen
man muss sich diese beim einchecken
schräg halten
ich weiß ich hab da so drin und ich las
auch ungern jemanden und hildegard
schweinsberg genannt oma börse ist in
diesem haus geboren angefangen hier zu
arbeiten hat sie da war sie noch ein
junges mädchen drei kinder großgezogen
zwei ehrenmänner überlebt früher ging es
hier rund
bis jetzt dass alles so ausgegangen wir
haben auch ein bisschen respekt trotzdem
ich schon vor allem binden
fast jeder ist stammgast in der börse
alle kennen sich seit jahrzehnten war
herr zahno das erste mal hier
das war vor 57 jahren
herr und frau der baum kommen immer
donnerstags für bockwurst kaffee und
frisch gezapftes einst aber natürlich
kommen sie auch wegen immer börse viele
die früher in der börse ein und ausging
sind inzwischen gestorben
immer börse aber ist immer noch da egal
wie charmant sie eingeladen wird sie
trinkt nie mit seit 30 jahren schon
nicht mehr kopfrechnen und kopfschmerzen
vertragen sie nicht reich wurde und wird
sie hier nicht aber die einnahmen decken
die kosten und irgendwie geht es ja auch
um mehr in der börse um die gemeinschaft
dass die börse mal schließt will sich
keiner vorstellen
mit 87 jahren immer noch täglich 100
gläser spülen trockenen kontrollieren
bibelstellen abrechnungen machen
immerhin hat oma börse inzwischen eine
halbtags hilfe angestellt
[Musik]
die rechte schulter auf zehn jahre das
ist wohl von dem wirtschaft zwei mal ist
sie hingefallen beim letzten mal war sie
sogar im krankenhaus und bat den arzt
sie schnell wieder fit zu machen denn
ihr gasthof wartet die frage steht für
alle gäste im raum brauchtümer börse
nicht mehr ruhe
das liegt mir nicht
und ich brauche die menschen und wenn
ich meine tür abschließen und eine clubs
unter anderem klub für das kann ich gar
nicht mit anderen drei kinder sieben
enkel und fünf urenkel hat sie aber
keiner möchte die börse übernehmen also
den gast zu verkaufen
die leute hier haben mir gesagt weißt du
was der cristo höchstes 80.000 ja das
lottospiel sie gehört dazu
ganz schön frech aber die kriegen auch
contra vor mir zurück
nein wenn das zukunft wird hauen wir
auch beim portsmouth und das wissen sie
denn ganz genaueres sagen sie auch also
bei oma börse kann ich jene tun was er
will und wer wie herr zahno einen über
den durst getrunken hat dem organisiert
oma börse die heimfahrt
was wäre neuhaus ohne die börse wer
herkommt geht verschlingt mit oder ohne
alkohol
so schön kann das leben sein